good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on sensor it's the bet that
rocked Britain two guys making a wager
doesn't often become a global news event
but my challenge to the Prime Minister
on his plan to send Asylum Seekers to
Rwanda triggered an enormous reaction
and appears to have triggered an
enormous number of people here's a
reminder of what actually happened I'll
bet you ,000 to a refugee charity you
don't get anybody on those planes before
the election will you take that bet well
I well I want to get the people on the
planes right of of course I want to get
the people on the plane, right I want to
get the people on the plane and and you
say you scratching your head Albania is
an example of why it's working we
created a new returns agreement with
Albania it meant that if people came
here illegally we could send them back
and you know what they stopped coming R
Rwanda will do the same thing for us I
do not think it's going to work for you
okay well we'll have to agree to
disagree that's my Grim prediction but
you don't have an alternative way to
solve that problem then uh no I'm not
prime
minister yet and here here's just a
small sample of the Fallout which is
vied with news of the king's health for
headline coverage and even made it to
the houses of
Parliament how frustrating for you that
yesterday our prime minister said that
he was willing to risk
,000 on the basis of a bet and it was a
charity bet wasn't it I didn't have a
problem with it at all to be honest with
you I think two multi-millionaires
having a bet amongst themselves it was
absolutely appalling I've never heard
such garbage um come out from a a
politician in my life was it deeply
distasteful as labor have called it or
would he have been criticized for not
backing the BET as one conservative
commentator has argued can you confirm
for the house Mr Deputy speaker that a
1,000 direct pecuniary personal interest
is one which should be registered and
declared through the house
authorities well Rich soon Act political
Rivals are feasting on the moment as
you'd expect the lib dens called it
shameful the S SMP said it's grotesque
and rather hysterically I thought
reported the Prime Minister for
breaching the ministerial code as they
put it Labour says it proves he's out of
touch they also posted this ad saying
while your pockets are bear rishi's
betting with a grand he has to spare not
the greatest poetry I think I've read in
a while but first things first they
didn't actually use the right handshake
there Labour party they want to think
about that that's him thanking me at the
end of the in you not accepting the BET
and where I come from Mr Prime Minister
you might try and wle off the hook but a
handshake Cal bet uh secondly it's worth
noting that Rishi sunak has now braved
two extended uncensored interviews with
me while he's been prime minister Sakia
stama who wants to be prime minister has
repeatedly told me to my face he'll come
on the show and has pre appeared
precisely zero times so when a lot of
the labor MPS hit social media today led
by Jess Phillips saying my my God if he
can't even cope with Pierce Morgan what
hope has he got with Vladimir Putin well
your leader doesn't appear to be able to
cope with me at all former labor spin do
aliser Campbell you may remember him he
spun us into an illegal war that cost
the deaths of over a million people
posted most of the audience at my book
event tonight were unaware of the sunac
Rwanda bet when I described The Exchange
there were literally sharp intakes of
breath and reactions of disgust in the
audience if it crossed alistar's mind
that that might have been the moment
they remembered what he did when he was
in Downing Street with Tony
Blair so a lot of reaction um and I
don't know how I feel about this other
than to say that when I see Carol vman
an old friend of mine used to work with
me at the Daily Mirror tweeting
hysterically resign rishy Zak about the
bet you're an utter disgrace to his
country and forgotten sitcom actor
Robert Lindsay he was good don't get me
wrong loved him as Wolfie Smith lamented
did dear anyone with an ounce of
humanity a PM and a TV presenter having
a bet on Desperate people's lives and so
on and so on and so on I do think a lot
of people may have lost the plot in the
Maelstrom of pearl clutching in the last
24 hours and forgotten actually that I
did start the process of this wager by
saying the BET proceeds would go to a
refugee charity I was actually trying to
flush out the prime minister's
conviction and a policy that I believe
has always been doomed to failure and is
bad for this country he was trying to
underscore his genuine belief that it
could work and I guess you could say he
was putting his money where his mouth is
and we all know he has plenty of money
to do that with but like I say no one
ends up with any money here other than a
refugee charity and what is almost
certainly going to happen I suspect is
that I will win this beted nobody will
end up being sent to Rwanda on a plane
and a refugee charity will be £1,000
better Better Off You could argue that's
quite a good win-win all around well the
Prime Minister himself was asked to
clarify the wager this morning I'm being
totally honest I'm not a betting person
and I was taken totally by surprise in
the middle of uh that interview and the
point I was trying to get was it a
mistake to shake his hand on no well the
point I was trying to get across I said
I was taken totally by surprise was it a
mistake to take my hand well I'm not
Hannibal Lector um the best questions
are always a surprise even for prime
ministers it should be noted he has not
officially withdrawn on the BET and I
wouldn't let him handshakes a handshake
uh former Tory leader William hay though
had some interesting tips on how he
would have handled this he said he'd
have attacked me with his martial arts
what do you do there William he how do
you do do you shake his hand do you make
the BET do you think that's all right or
do you do you avoid that land mine be
really nice to do a judo move on it
would holding out his hand um but
however that's the sort of thing I can
fantasize about today and couldn't have
done when I was a party leader uh so um
to bat the hand
away fantasizing about grappling me in a
judo hold this is a man who wanted to be
prime minister should be known as the
same William ha who once boasted of
drinking 14 pints a day obviously a
tough cookie uh and Sam coats over at
Sky News gave this analysis you know the
point about that exchange with Piers
Morgan um and and and actually you know
listening to Rich try not very well to
defend it this morning he's like just
gets dragged into stuff you know but
you've got to deal with more difficult
people than PEB you got to deal with
Vladimir Putin who says that put is more
difficult than me what do you base that
on shame on you Sam Co I was going to
mention James o' over LBC was ranting
away about me but he does it so often
and he's so insufferably irritating I'm
going to spare you my own viewers from
having to even see his face now at the
heart of all this is a serious issue
I've said repeatedly I don't believe the
Rwanda plan is either practical or
affordable or indeed Humane I think the
PM is finally making some progress on
illegal immigration with the boats he's
got them down substantially thanks to a
deal with Albania but this rander plan
as I said to him to his face is a
cack-handed plan that is just never
going to work and the BET prime minister
most definitely stands when Jord have
discussed this is talk to V contributor
and lawyer Paul Aron Adrian the author
journalist Paul Mason and talk TV
International editor Isabelle oakshaw
okay right well I've got Paul and Paula
and I know where you're both going to
come at me from uh Paul look I I I was
surprised it blew up Miss big if I'm
honest with him because really the point
I was making was it's for charity this
bet but are you going to put your money
where your mouth is and I can see the
way it's it's played out obviously very
differently to how it felt in the room
at the time what what was your view of
this well I'm like you I'm against the
Rwanda plan I don't think work I think
it's unfair I think it's probably
illegal in international law and it
costs a lot of money but if I was in
favor of it I would try and present it
to the public a in a little bit more
sober way I thought it trivialized it
because it it may be that Richie doesn't
know this but there were some migrants
put on a plane in June 2022 refugees to
go to Rwanda stopped by the courts they
were dragged onto that plane and chained
to the floor and I accept that
deportations have to happen in a fair
migration system some people have to be
deported but when we do that on our all
our behalves we've got to maintain the
idea to the rest of the world that we're
Humane and we care about those people
even if they fail to were you J you said
you you found it morally r or whatever
you said I said it was morally vacuous
right A lot of people said similar
sentiments I think there's a uov poll
says 72% of Britain think it was
unacceptable for sunak to accept my bet
but I haven't seen much reference to the
fact that proceeds are going to a
refugee charity let let people may have
missed that it was a news making
interview let's accept that the the
point is First It's a grand you I was in
my local Tesco just now and and watching
you know young moms looking at whether
or not they can afford what's on the
shelves a grand to such people sounds
like a lot even in North Allon and
Richmond you know I'm not sure how many
Richies constituents would have found
that very tasteful but then they all
know they all know he's stinking rich I
call him stinking rich last time I
interviewed him but the but the issue
then is let's not trivialize the fate of
a lot of people a lot of Tory MPS not
just Mr sunak often say we can't wait to
to to see the planes take off when I
hear them say that I think what about
the people in the planes they've you
know as a journalist I've been to
Morocco interviewed people on wastelands
people from ner and said to them look
when you get here you're going to risk
dying to get here there'll be a lot of
racism when you get here and you'll be
poor why you you doing it and they say
come to ner and and you'll find out I.E
the idea that the deterrent effect is
going to stop them coming well I don't
think it'll be a deterrent effect I mean
Paul I'll bring you in here I just don't
think it is I don't think it works on
any level they've already admitted the
government pretty much that even if they
do get it through Parliament and get
these people onto planes we're only
talking about a couple of hundred people
a vast expense maybe three 400 million
pounds to the British taxpayer it makes
no commercial economic sense whatsoever
but my biggest problem with it is I
think we should be a country which can
deal with illegal immigration properly
with a proper policy and the far bigger
problem at the moment of a soaring legal
immigration issue which is exploding our
entire population um but also we should
be a country which can take Asylum
Seekers who warrant coming in as Asylum
Seekers and if we send people to Rwanda
and even if they fulfill the criteria
for entry as as we don't let them come
back what Have We Become as a country
absolutely and I think I just want to be
able to answer your question in terms of
you being surprised at the reaction to
this bet I'm disappointed that you're
surprised um I'm not surprised it was
crass it was crude um you were playing
with people's lives no I was that's
ridiculous that's a ridiculous thing to
say people have died I
wasn't to this I'm actually trying to
stop those people's lives being played
with but you but you
played what I was doing what I was doing
two wey men what's the weal to do
suggested that oh let's just you know
put our put our hands in our back
pockets and pull out ,000 to a refugee
charity finish the sentence but we lost
the refugee charity you should use it
let me let me should lose why we lost
the refugee it seems to be your solution
is Refuge Char shouldn't get ,000 no
because rishy has already spent
£240 million of the British taxpayers
money
on this failed event well he didn't say
to be fair in the interview where the
was coming to me did you watch the
intervie and and did you see the whole
debate about Rwanda I didn't I so the
idea that I'm playing with people's
lives when I was actively trying to stop
the British prime minister from going
through with a policy which I think is
playing with people's lives I find that
offensive well tell what's what's
happened is Piers is that you're a slick
interrogator and what you did I'm a
journalist and what you did was you led
used
lishy onto that I and he was like it was
reminiscent of bamb beond ice skates
wasn't it it was just a car crash and
how he can really contain himself today
me he must be cringing so yes it was a
joke maybe not to you but clearly get a
wording I did what people do to many of
his constituents up and down the country
all the time right they have an argument
they reach a place where they're not
agreeing they go I'll bet you you can't
get this to work right I didn't mean
mean it as any insult to people I was
trying to stop people being in my view
it mistreated by this country right now
the surprise to me was only that the
Prime Minister accepted the bet now that
may have been a misjudgment on his part
he was probably calculating in the
moment you know what if I don't it looks
like I don't believe in my policy if
damned if I do damned if I don't and
maybe that was a sharp Moment by me to
flush that out that hesitation by him
but I do think I mean Paul I do think
some of the reaction has been ridiculous
well I haven't seen all the reaction but
what I would say is I don't share your
criticism of of you you know as a
journalist when one makes a news making
interview you know you want to make the
headlines um you spent a long time with
him I watched the whole interview a long
time and what was clear to me was that
the Prime Minister was in many ways
accepting your premises at every point
in the argument and that as a human
being let alone journalist when you find
someone doing that you you do start to
wonder should this guy be running the
country and let's see how far he'll go
I've done that in interviews with people
where I felt that that really they're
out to their depth now I don't want to
be unfair to the Prime Minister because
any live interview with a senior
journalist is a tough thing but in the
end it I just think he's out of touch
and and the out of touch I have no
problem with you offering him uh to to
bet a grand for a refugee charity but
what what I do have is the idea that he
th thrown that sort of sort of funny
enough to sort of think oh I can do well
I think he I think he flamed him
actually I mean let be be fair I think
he flamed him in the moment he didn't
really know what to do and people
criticize and say what he should do he's
only being Prime Min auth he should have
exerted his authority of course every
prime minister will tell you and I'm
sure you've had conversations with him
that they are at their best the day
after they lose their jobs right they
get fully trained properly experienced
and then they get fired let me bring in
Isabelle oaka has been listening
patiently to this Isabelle um a lot of
Hysteria about what I thought was a
fairly
sharp piece of journalistic stunter to
elicit a genuinely fascinating response
which it
did well what a load of sanctimonious
twaddle from both Paul and Paula I mean
Paula hasn't even uh watched the whole
interview so it's rather difficult to
imagine how she can possibly be
pronouncing on it B said she was
disappointed and I too am disappointed
Piers because I think you could have bet
a whole lot more
on that policy not working have you
fallen on hard times or
something I mean I honestly I just came
up with a figure in the moment I had no
idea what I was really going to come up
with I just thought it'd be interesting
interesting to test result interesting
to see what he I just you could afford a
lot more well probably I don't think
yeah I mean both of you could have
afforded a lot more and at the end of
the day which whatever the outcome of
the BET whether you're right and the
policy doesn't work which I have happen
to completely agree with you I think
it's a very safe bet or he's right and
he manages to get this policy off the
ground Refugee charity is ,000 better
off so I'm really struggling to see how
anyone can genuinely criticize that it's
the first time I've ever heard either a
successful TV presenter or a prime
minister being criticized for being too
generous in donating money to charity
well I said exactly what I thought I
thought honestly and they all
deliberately left that bit out of it so
they're all ranting away about rich
people spending all nobody mentioned in
their critiques that this was actually a
bet for charity that's how I prefaced
the whole thing um what was interesting
I think about the interview Isabelle I
know you've seen it all now was there
were other things in that interview that
I felt were much more newsworthy one was
where he basically called K starma a
terror sympathizer uh over this band
group we had that NHS doctor on the show
who's who leads the UK arm of that now
prescribed terror group in this country
and he basically called starma a terror
sympathizer for trying to stop them
becoming a prescribed Group by acting
for them and the other thing I thought
was uh really newsworthy uh was the the
confirmation by the Prime Minister that
one of his key five pledges to get NHS
waiting list down which he actually
coupled with sorting out the crisis in
the A&E uh he failed on let's take a
look NHS waiting list we have not made
enough progress you failed on that
Pledge yes because you said any sh
waiting this will fall but the waiting
is still nearly half a million more than
it was at the start of last year so My
mother is 79 and she had a heart attack
three months ago and she was taken to
her local hospital and she was seen when
she got there and then she was put on a
trolley in A&E in a corridor for nearly
hours the heart monitor battery ran out
nobody fixed it at one stage no nurse
came for 3 or 4 hours and she was also
terrified of course having been told
you've had a heart attack that no one
was putting her into the unit and
actually trying to fix her now once she
got up there the treatment she got was
world class but I you know I brought
this one picture to show you that's you
know that's my mom and when she really
needed the NHS yeah eventually the HS
came through but she could have died on
that trolley and I think that's
shocking yeah that is a shocking story
and I'm really glad that she's feeling
better now and send her my best and I'm
glad she got the treatment that she
needed this was a Monday night prime
minister this wasn't even the weekend
yeah it's not even a major city this is
Brighton and there were 40 yard people
on trolleys in a
corridor well you know I got an email
today which we we're trying to
corroborate Isabelle but it was from
somebody else exactly the same Hospital
whose mother Di died on a trolley in
that A&E and was there 24 hours well and
I I think this is going on up and down I
want to pick up on that yeah I really
want to pick up on that because if I
were the labor party or any opposition
party I would play that particular clip
of your interview on a loop and look at
the prime minister's reaction to me this
is the most insightful bit of the
interview there is something very very
wrong about the prime minister's
reaction to your story he just has he
shows no empathy there is no form of
shock in his reaction to your story he's
robotic about it and that really really
jars with me and you know I am so glad
to hear that when your mom was finally
taken up onto the ward that she got the
treatment that you described you said it
was world class um but you in a sense
you were lucky look my mother recently
died in an NH h s hospital I am sorry to
say that she died in front of a lot of
people that none of us had any privacy
and in the seconds after she died my
sisters and I were taken into a store
cupboard because there was nowhere
private for us to go so I wasn't
planning on sharing that story but the
prime minister's reaction to your story
has if you like triggered me to do that
because it was so lacking in any real
empathy for than many many thousands of
people tonight who are on Hospital
trolleys and are not getting the
treatment that they deserve the NHS is
failing and he's admitted it and it's
failed on his
watch yeah well I'm very sorry about it
Mom you and I have talked about that
before and it incredibly sad for you and
I feel very fortunate that my mother was
able to come through it you know she to
have a heart attack in your late 70s and
then spend seven hours on a trolley
thinking what is happening to me with
the heart monitor regularly running out
of batteries and no one seemed to notice
him was scary um Paul what you what did
you make of that part of the interview
again I was looking at his face and
thinking look prime minister doesn't get
to meet a lot of ordinary people and
when he does you know you were very
measured with him but imagine we can all
imagine a voter saying the same story
what would happen in general is that the
people behind him would just gently Edge
him away and I think that what if he can
learn anything it is listen to these
ordinary sto stories I bet every single
one of us including all your studio uh
staff could tell the same story I've got
stories of 48 hours in a& I've had so
many in the last two days but it's but
so the NHS is failing it so happens that
we've had one party in government for 14
years but I'd say you know there is a
long-term problem with NHS I actually
think my hunch I don't know about you
and Isabelle my hunch is that people
care a lot more about these stories of
everyday hardship than they do about
whether the Rwanda scheme deports 200
and actually care Paula more about the
reality of human stories than they do
about the over Topline statistics you
can hear 7.6 million people on a waiting
list you can hear A&E's out of control
when you actually have a loved one
trapped in that nightmare of waiting for
an L to save their life or waiting to
get into through A&E it is terrify
absolutely and I think there's two
things here the first is that you're
right you know when he when he's
approached by a member of the public we
saw it just a couple of weeks ago um he
laughed in response
to he was C of C he didn't know what to
do but well that CLI was cut unfairly
long that also happens now the second
point I wanted to make though was about
the disconnect it's the disconnect that
we recognize in this story about your
mother and it's the same disconnect that
we recognize in terms of the bed we're
talking about um our prime minister who
doesn't have the capacity to be
sensitive enough to understand that when
he's asked about making a bet on what is
something that for many is a life or
death situation be it about the NHS be
it about Rwanda that he can just limply
shake your hand um on a policy that we
know or we are being told aren't we that
he doesn't even agree with but he's
having to push through look I like isab
I wasn't going to say this but I think I
will just to be balanced about it
because the idea that he doesn't care
for example about my mother and what
happened to her and whatever facial
reaction he showed at the time I can
tell you he sent her a big bunch of
flowers yesterday and then he followed
up and called her without any recourse
to me whatsoever uh called her for 10
minutes and had a really lovely chat
with her the problem is there you're
you if it was nice thing to do you know
if only had sent my mom a bunch of
course he can't s he can't everybody but
my point being that I don't think he's a
heartless I don't think he didn't care I
don't think he's Harless I think he does
care but I think that you know I give
them a little bit of slack politicians
for facial expressions when they're
being jumped with stuff they're not
really sure what it's all about and I
can just say that my mother was very
touched by both the flowers and the
phone call and greatly appreciated what
he said to her uh and she certainly came
away thinking this guy does care now I
completely accept I'm a television
presenter and it was a big interview
everyone's talking about it and not
everyone gets that Prime ministerial
treatment but he did do that and I've
not had a prime minister do that to any
of my family before we're not voting uh
for the conservative party on the basis
of whether Rishi has sent your mom
flowers of course
that's not no listen we run out of time
I'm simply trying to balance up the he
doesn't care narrative which I don't
think is fair he He does care I saw it I
spoke to him afterwards uh for quite a
while actually after the interview he
definitely cares right um but we'll have
to doing about well that well that the
question is can can any leader right now
F NHS is a much bigger question I'm not
sure D well maybe maybe and he'll get he
may get a chance before the end of the
year to prove it we got we got to leave
it there guys I'm sorry we run out of
time thank thank you uh Paula Paul and
Isabelle thank you all very much indeed
I appreciate
it